at first glance this may look like an
abstract painting on a wall but look
again and it's actually a work of art on
the side of a truck this is the truck
art project an initiative in Madrid 29
of Spain's most established artists have
taken part Ebrahim lakiya is one of them
[Music]
it's a painting and movement this
project was a challenge but in a
positive sense paintings normally hang
on walls and not between cars that are
zipping by kid fuga Matias paintings
usually hang in galleries and museums
including the well-known rena sofia in
the Spanish capital but he stepped out
of his normal element to participate in
this project
[Music]
Maria Vargas also took part she's been
active as a professional artist for 15
years
her works often involve graphic allegory
intervention acaba the truck art project
is now an important part of my work I
work a lot with the symbol of the Sacred
Heart and since this symbol is so
important in my art I decided to put it
on the truck
it's a symbol on the artist for the
truck art project were chosen by the
curators
[Music]
when they contacted me they first wanted
to do only a street art and I came up
with the idea of bringing on indoor
painters and and different artists are
not normally used to show in their art
in the in the streets and normally they
are only displayed in museums galleries
or indoors
aníbal Rica is also one such artist her
works are often quite colorful and
playful
aside from painting a truck she was also
commissioned to paint a mural on the
transport companies grounds it is a
fiocchis with Bonilla it was a big
challenge to adapt to this format
without formatting in such a short
period of time
it's rima if we exit on T but it was
amazing to take part in this project
project Athena forgetting my parameter a
look at the sea again whenever it was
something new for me because I'm used to
working in closed rooms with viewable
formats for matter the truck our project
is the brainchild of entrepreneur hi
Mikasa he started this transport company
five years ago but his true passion is
art which is displayed on the walls both
inside and outside of the company
Koza funded the truck art project with
money from his transport firm it is
important that companies these days use
part of their profit to return to the to
the society and and and and I think that
it is a social responsibility or
corporate responsibility and and and we
are promoting art and letting some
people enjoy art
[Music]
the trucks operate all over Spain so the
public at large have a chance at
spotting them on the road or in town for
now their numbers are limited but cosa
is looking to expand the project to 100
trucks or more an early next year there
will also be an event where all the
trucks can be seen together in one big
Roadshow
[Music]